and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome to episode 151 today
we're gonna talk about donating selling
recycling reusing and trashing your
excess stuff Yemen so I think we call
this one donating cool and our first
question today is from Christina in
Sacramento I'm going through a lot of my
stuff and I'm struggling with
determining what is something I should
donate and what is something that I
should try and make a profit from so I
see value in these items not necessarily
value for myself and and my lifestyle
but I do see value or potential for you
know making a few a few bucks here in
there like on shoes or clothes but I
also think that it's easier for me to
just drop off a box at the goodwill and
donate but I'm struggling with making
that determination as far as what would
make me happy would it make me happy to
donate these items to someone who might
find use for them or would it make me
happy to you know make me try and make a
profit off of these items that I don't
find value in so Ryan I can't tell
Christina what's going to make her happy
necessarily but there are a few like
sort of key words that I might rephrase
if I were her the first thing she asked
a question or really made the statement
she's struggling to determine whether
she should donate or try to make a
profit from these things I wouldn't try
to make a profit from the things that
you're selling because you probably
bought them when they were new yeah and
you're probably unless it's some sort of
weird Hummel collector's item in most
cases you're going to lose the vast
majority of the value you paid for the
thing because most of the possessions
that we own are depreciating right
assets in fact in her case they're not
even assets at all they're liability
now all right because she's she isn't
getting value from them in fact she's
getting what I would call negative value
which would be a really good title for
an essay podcast Shawn we should we
should craft something like that but um
the the the negative value of the stuff
because there is this additional weight
there's the psychological weight of
holding on to these things the refusal
to let go and that causes I mean clearly
she's calling up so it causes what
anxiety discontent stress overwhelm and
and maybe it's not a high level of
stress but it's this low level of
anxiety that is ebbing throughout her
life and that adds up over time man yeah
I mean that's a clear sign that she's
got to do something with those things
you know it's funny Christina if you
were to just as a Christina Chris yeah
Christina I got a right she preggos by
Christine for short anyway Christine no
no I I'm just I'm messing myself up um
Christina what I was gonna say is you
could donate everything right now you
know I turn this podcast off right now
and donate everything and you're gonna
be okay
like there's no doubt about that so the
question isn't whether or not you know
what's the right decision meaning oh you
know if I don't sell this stuff then I'm
gonna miss out on some money like you
didn't really expect to have that money
to begin with right
so it'd be like if you if I was walking
down the sidewalk and I saw one hundred
dollar bill on the sidewalk I mean of
course I'm gonna pick it up but if I
didn't pick it up my life wouldn't be
any different Christina your life isn't
gonna be any different if you donate
every single one of these things now so
any money what you're saying anymore
that she does make if she does decide to
sell and it's sort of a windfall in a
way yeah pretty much
so look at it that way as anything that
you sell is you know kind of gravy on
top and then you got to decide how much
of gravy you want Christina maybe maybe
it's good to set up some rules around
this because I think what she's facing
right now is she sort of paralyzed by
that that decision right where remember
the the Seth Godin that sa you and I
were talking about the other day where
he's talking about the canceling
something like it was something that
you're putting off cancel cancel the
thing so so in in this sort of analogy
here you want to cancel these
items you wanted to cancel these
physical items and then give yourself
one week to do something with them yes
so just to rephrase what you're saying
is she needs to set an end date for all
of these things to be out of her house
yeah and one or two things are going to
happen
well a she has to commit to that ending
non-negotiable pick a date stick to it
that's step number one right and then
the second step is yeah you're either
gonna be Cristina's gonna be motivated
to sell that stuff or the end dates
gonna come and she's gonna be like yeah
they really have time to sell him it's
gonna go ahead and donate all of it but
either way right she's gotta honor that
end date no I totally agree man so even
so maybe the let's put some parameters
around out my own life when I was a
question I would ask her a few questions
one is do you have any debt then I would
be more aggressive about selling things
to try to pay off the debt yeah I
certainly don't want to come across like
you know if there's something sitting
there for 20 that she can sell for $20
20 bucks is 20 bucks and if it's easy
for her to sell that item and get 20
bucks then do that like we're not we're
not saying to just yet don't worry about
the money you're right if she has debt
that's more of a reason for her to dig
into it but this is what she's got to
ask herself how long is it gonna take me
to sell that item for $20 yeah cuz your
time worth yeah if it's gonna take her
20 hours to sell an item for $20 she's
got a post-it she's got a you know
filter through all the people trying to
you know pay half as much she has to
repost it if it expires and she doesn't
get to print so yes she has to figure
out what her time is worth absolutely
yeah and that's an individual question
right everybody's billionaires whose
time I mean they'd be better off just
donating the car because the amount of
time it takes selling a car would just
not be worth it for them because their
time is worth a particular dollar amount
yeah now neither one of us are
millionaires or especially not
billionaires and so you have to take
that into consideration what is your
time worth put a dollar amount on it but
then also what is the psychological cost
that goes on top of that because let's
say your time you know you're working
somewhere and you're making twenty bucks
an hour then you can say well my time
was worth twenty dollars an hour
and if I can sell this one item in half
an hour for twenty dollars well then I'm
making forty bucks an hour that makes
whole lot of sense for me to sell this
thing however just because you think you
can sell something for 20 bucks doesn't
mean you necessarily will and so that's
why I think that in date of a week is so
important I used to say 30 days when I
read that Seth Godin essay I was like oh
and we'll put a link to that in the show
notes Shawn it's about it's about
cancelling big projects and saying I'm
either gonna cancel this or I'm gonna
take massive action on the thing and I
think that's really where Christina is
right now and and I would be even more
aggressive with settling things if I had
debt and so for me I'd put some
parameters around that we have something
called the 3030 rule when it comes to
buying new things and it's if something
costs more than $30 then I'm gonna wait
at least 30 hours to bring it into my
life well maybe you you take a iteration
of that rule and you make that
applicable to your life where hey maybe
if I can get more than 30 bucks for this
or whatever your time was worth and I
spend less than an hour on on that
whatever that dollar amount is for the
hour and I'm gonna spend less in now
we're trying to sell this thing now for
me I a baby came my best friend when I
was trying to get out of debt and
selling a bunch of things yeah there
were for me it was above 20 bucks
anything over 20 bucks I would try to
put it on eBay and I didn't always
succeed I held on to some of those
things way too long because of the sunk
cost fallacy right yeah that you nailed
it dude she's got to get comfortable son
cost I mean that is that is ultimately
where this is leading so she's gonna
decide okay here are the things that I
can get some money out of here are the
things that are worth my time to sell
and everything else it is sunk cost
you're never gonna get that that that
money back that you paid for those items
but it's okay because maybe someone else
will get value out of those items and
you've created a you know situation for
someone else to have something maybe
they typically would not have had if it
wasn't for you donating that to a you
know your favorite donation or your
favorite charity or whatever it may be
let's talk about a few of those
charities so if you're selling stuff I
reckon I mean I tend to recommend three
places to people because this is what
I've I've used two of them I've not used
the third one yeah if you're selling
stuff Craigslist has really my go to it
oh yeah in fact we go back she just sold
her car on on Craigslist you have two
weeks ago and someone came out from
Idaho
up the car and it all worked out so
Craigslist is a great place to sell
things you're also gonna get inundated
with spammers and you have to consider
that as part of the cost they're gonna
be people who email you excuse me madam
is the item still for sale I'm stuck in
the UK but I have but I have a business
friend in America who would like to take
a look at in order to pay you nine
thousand dollars you need to wire me
$500 first to make sure that and so
you're gonna you have to be very weary
of that but Craigslist is a great place
to sell especially bigger eyes
recently we sold an old coffee table on
Craigslist we sold an old end table and
it wasn't old it was just it was old to
us we weren't using it anymore from when
Bex and I combined households and then
we had this extra table on this other
extra table in table and sold the
because it was like perfect timing to
his kids going back to school and
they're like yeah we'll buy that for 50
bucks or 100 bucks even though the sunk
costed me was like no that table cost me
250 dollars and my first reaction to
that is I should sell for 240 then mm-hm
and if we get back to Christina's
original question what she's saying is
well I'm trying to figure whether
whether or not I should make a profit
well for me that would mean I have to
sell the table for 260 bucks and then
I'm just going to hold on to that
begrudgingly for a long time and that
psychological cost is going to compound
there's compound interest on some of
these psychological costs a little bit
of anxiety you're feeling right now will
be twice as much a month from now a year
from now all of a sudden you're stressed
out you don't realize why and it's that
fear of letting go and so I think I
think Christina if you want to sell the
stuff you have to give yourself a
timeline so pick 10 things that you
really feel good about selling that's
worth your time selling sell those
things you can't sell them the first
week then donate them oh the third place
I would recommend selling stuff is
Poshmark and only a reason I know about
that place is because podcast Sean's
wife sells some stuff off watch mark
from time there was another charity you
wanted to bring up oh there's so that
those are the places to sell there's a
few places with respect to charities
because a lot of charities are so
localized
goodwill is the big exception I really
like goodwill I enjoy donating stuff to
Goodwill for a couple reasons one is
it's convenient too is they have 2,700
donation locations yeah around around
the United States and they the in but I
understand people's aversion to it
because like well if I donate my clothes
they're gonna sell it and then how I
make sure those clothes get to people in
need well goodwill is still a charity
they take that money last year I think
they may 2.8 billion dollars 84% of
which is used for charitable giving that
non overhead related expenses that's
pretty phenomenal it's pretty awesome I
mean a charity that uses a they're a
United Way I doubt it uses 84% of their
revenue the their donations to for
charitable goods and so they in fact
let's put a link there they're in in the
show notes to show a lot of the good
that goodwill does without getting
bogged down in the stats of it goodwill
does a ton of good now now one thing
Ryan today that that is difficult that
to get over so will they pay their CEO a
lot of money well apparently their CEO
manages the the company really well and
they're able to donate eighty four
percent of the revenue they make as a
result isn't that a good thing yeah it's
never bothered me that they make money
off of a dude ever it's never I've never
even thought about it until someone said
something like oh I don't do that
because I'm giving them something for
free and then they're selling it but
it's like they have the infrastructure
they have the means and it's not like
they're trying to gouge people with
their prices I mean I don't if you've
ever shopped at Goodwill I know both of
us have and like dude they're not
gouging for prices so I am totally happy
to give my goods to someone who has the
infrastructure to redistribute those
goods to people who actually need them
like I have that has never bothered me
now well I think that if you're a woman
and you have clothes to donate maybe the
best place is not to donate to Goodwill
because especially if you have like
professional clothes there's a charity
called Dress for Success and what they
do is they help women who are
interviewing or they're they're trying
to they're trying to get professional
clothes and so though I believe they'll
even pick it up for
so Dress for Success will put a link to
that in the show notes and the last
thing I wanna recommend because
charities are so the donation places are
so hyper localized like I remember back
in Missoula we would go to a donation
warehouse and in fact they would pick
stuff up from you
in fact we bought some furniture from
them when we first met Missoula that's
how we learned about them and people
were donating their stuff and so we got
value from some of the things we bought
from them relatively inexpensively and
then they'll pick up your old mattresses
and stuff like that but you probably
don't have donation warehouse wherever
you live if you're listening to this
unless you're in Missoula but if you go
to donation town org that's how I found
donation warehouse you just type in your
zip code and it will tell you well here
are the three places in or near your zip
code that will come pick up and it's
very specific they'll pick up mattresses
this place will pick up toys this place
will pick up anything and so if you go
to donation town or you can find the
local charity for you or if that doesn't
help you out especially with things like
batteries those are hard to get rid of
you know especially we live in
California it's illegal for us to throw
out batteries in the trash can hmm oh
Best Buy takes them here but and so does
Target but wherever you are you can just
google where do I do or where do I
recycle batteries where where do i
donate blank in your local area and
you'll find like the the specific
charity to which you can donate you
these these excess things that you're
not able to sell yeah Christina I mean
really get clear on what you want your
your life to look like or what you want
your your the things in your house how
do you want them to to appear in your
house what spaces do you want to fill up
whatever it is like just get clear on
what that ideal scenario is anything
that distracts you from getting to that
scenario you've got a oh we need another
towel okay Sean do you have a small
towel what I'm getting at is is like we
will start to flinch at stuff yeah
we'll start to flinch at oh you know I
this is how I want my life to be but in
order to get it that way I need to get
rid of this one thing and all that one
thing I paid a hundred bucks for and
maybe I could get twenty bucks out of it
those those little bear
those little hurdles um jump over them
as quick as possible yeah if that means
just donating your stuff like I promise
you Christina's could it'd be way more
worth it to you than just to just get
rid of it than it is to sit here and
worry about every little nickel and dime
that you can make officer because the
the price tag or the money involved is
only one component of a much bigger
recipe and I love what you just said
about having a vision because that
vision is going to keep you on track
it's sort of the horizon or the
destination the direction is probably
the better way to put it your vision is
the direction in which you want to
travel now you'll get where your house
is closer to your vision and the vision
might shift a little bit it might pivot
slightly or might pivot significantly
once you start letting go of some of
these things and you're like wow I can
let go of more this is this is freeing I
feel lighter my house is way easier to
clean once you start getting rid of
these things and you get that that
momentum and that momentum carries you
forward letting go builds the muscle of
letting go even more Christina I'd love
to seen your copy of our book it's
called everything that remains it's my
favorite thing that we've ever written
and really it's a story story of me and
Ryan letting go and whether that's
selling and donating recycling reusing
trashing our excess stuff and the whole
process of letting go everything from
Ryan's 21 day packing party to just my
eighth month experiment and letting go
and so I think you'll find value in our
downsizing journeys so Shawn if you
could reach out to Kristina send her the
audio book version of everything that
remains if you like the podcast you'll
like the audio book version or if you
want the physical book or the e-book
we're happy to send those to you as well
our next question is from Don in Aurora
Illinois now that all of my friends and
family know that I've been declaring and
minimizing I found a lot of things that
I do want to give away to Fred because I
don't want to give it away just to
donate or just to a stranger I find
things that were meaningful to me and
I'd rather give it to somebody that is a
friend that comes to mind
ever worried that if I give it to them
they're going to be excited that I'm
just offloading my junk on to them do
you remember the time I tried to give
you all of those neckties when I was I
was simplifying my life I this is a 2009
yeah and and I had just discovered
minimalism and I realized how many damn
neckties I had I had at least two maybe
three necktie holders worth of neckties
I knew I had too many because sometimes
I would put more than one tie on the the
same sort of peg on the necktie holder I
had I've tried I probably gave you 70
ties yeah and they're really nice again
I'm still tied I kept like four of them
and then I just donated the rest but
yeah also dollars on neckties yeah what
did I spend thousands of dollars on
things I am embarrassed to admit that I
spent thousands of dollars man you know
it's funny like I I've never had anyone
be offended though by me offering them
them something I mean I could see where
the trepidation comes in it sounds to me
like you know in dawn I'm not you know
trying to say your friends are bad or
anything but it sounds to me like you
got friends who were trying to call you
out on you're afraid that they're gonna
call you out on something petty yeah and
and it sounds like maybe this is what
her friends do and she's and she's like
oh well this is what they always do so
if I go to them and offer them stuff
they're gonna continue to be petty or
they're gonna continue to do this well
me or maybe there's sort of two ways to
do there's a real petty
passive-aggressive nasty way yeah
there's a way where you and I like we
can rib each other in a way because we
know each other so well yeah but even
then I can't imagine that you would be
like oh good job minimalist pass and
you're taught you you would do it in a
way that was actually funny that
wouldn't make me feel concerned in fact
if you didn't want them you I'm sure it
would hilarity would ensue as soon as I
I tried to pass these off to you you
would do it in a way that was kind and
loving even if it was like ribbing me a
little bit yeah all done all you have to
do is just preface with your friends hey
you know that I've been simplifying my
life you know that I've been getting rid
of stuff and I've got a lot of nice
stuff
and I hate to just give it to Goodwill
do you need any stuff in fact here are
the specific things I have that I think
you might be in need of I'm not gonna be
offended if you don't take them I'm not
going to be mad if you tell me no but I
just wanted to offer you know my nicest
things that I'm getting rid of - my
closest friends and family and Dawn if
they judge you for that then get new
friends you know our friend Colin right
he's on tour right now we often call him
the third minimalist because he's the
guy who exposed us to this idea of
minimalism early on he's the first first
guy who first person out of the mini
mini minimalist that we've been inspired
by but he was sort of the first one and
even though we didn't want to live his
life we were really inspired by the fact
that he was able to uproot his life let
go of the superfluous and one way that
he donated a lot of this stuff to his
friends actually he was living here in
Los Angeles and he and his girlfriend
had a breakup party which in and of
itself is that was actually the
inspiration for the packing party yeah
yeah yeah he wrote about that let's put
a link to that sa podcast on in the show
notes yeah I definitely thought party
it's a great essay and he goes in-depth
in his book called my exile lifestyle
he's naked on the cover of that book
with a computer over his private parts
as soon as I feel comfortable taking a
naked picture I'm totally gonna recreate
that book cover I think because we're so
uncomfortable taking it would be better
for us to do it if you both put on 30
pounds for cover
yeah no I know you're going with this
man the the the garage sale room yeah
actually yeah the free yard sale room
that's um that's a great idea and so so
as they were getting ready to move him
and his his partner who they were
splitting up they they agreed together
like at midnight we're going to we're
going to change our facebook status so
that's that means it's official we're no
longer in a relationship at least I was
official I guess in 2008 or 2009
whenever that was and and but in that
process the 30 days leading up to it
they had a free yard sale room that they
took the the room that want one of the
rooms in their house and said hey that's
our yard sale room we don't want
anything in there if you would find
value and anything in that room then go
get it don't
show it to me just take it out of the
house if you're not gonna find value in
it
that's okay too we're gonna donate the
rest as soon as we're done with that and
so that gives that gives your friends
the option because it is better to give
someone the option than it is to thrust
upon them 70 necktie of course but even
then like it's not that big of a deal
right right although I mean I guess the
the what I'm saying here is what I
probably should have done it hey Ryan I
have 70 neckties yeah I'm no longer
going to use would you like any of these
yeah you gave me the option I remember
you were like no just whatever you keep
what you want and then just donate the
rest I was like oh okay I can do that
which we thought was the cost of taking
the ties they were nice ties I really
love this size dude I had I can't tell
you how many people in our old job and
our old corporation we worked for they
would tell me dude every time I see you
it looks like you're running for
president I'm assuming that's their way
of telling me that I dressed like almost
like too nice but I was happy to donate
the rest of them I think it's important
to also keep in mind that just because
you have gotten value from something
doesn't mean someone else will too and
that's one of the things we confuse but
I think the opposite is also true
just because you're no longer getting
value from something doesn't mean it's a
piece of trash someone else might get
value from it it's not going to
magically start bringing you value again
the the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
that I played with at age 7 if I hold on
to them now they're not gonna start late
all of a sudden Wow yeah I should start
playing with those again and when we we
Illustrated with such observed terms and
we can start to realize that a lot of
the physical possessions that we have
are sort of just grown up versions of
toys and and I'm not getting value from
this but maybe just maybe someone else
can so letting go of those neckties
sounds like you've got some value from
this absolutely and there's a there's a
better way to approach it for sure
though definitely so instead of giving
them maybe ask them if they need
anything maybe try out the donation or
the yard the free yard sale room and of
course maybe try to sell a few things if
especially if you're in debt done I
think that will
that well that will help you on your
journey of letting go determining what
things you should sell what things you
should donate and of course is a
leftover pile there's gonna be trash
there as well and we need to be upfront
and honest about that it's that you can
recycle things great if you can reuse
things great but it's already trash if
it's just sitting there in your house
collecting dust Don I'd love to send you
a copy of our book essential it's an
essay collection with a hundred and
fifty essays about simple living about
intentional living and it's sort of the
best of the minimalist I think there are
two chapters in particular that you'll
find value and there's a chapter on
stuff actually three chapters there's
another chapter in there four chapters
because there's a chapter on minimalism
there's a chapter on stuff there's a
chapter on relationships and there's a
chapter on contribution because that's
one of the things to think about here
because the stuffs collecting dust in
your house you're not really
contributing beyond yourself but if you
let go of it you can contribute beyond
yourself in a meaningful way so Sean I
think you reach out to Don's center of
the audio book of essential essay the
essay collection or the book book or the
e-book if she wants those all right yeah
we'd love to hear what you have to say
so if you have a comment or tip about
donating or selling including advice for
any of our callers today leave us a
voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists com
where our favorite comments and tips on
a future episode and stay tuned to the
end of this episode for this week's
listener comments and tips Ryan what
time is it it's time for our lightning
round where we answer questions from
social media indeed we do we're on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram at the
minimalists during the lightning round
this is where Ryan and I each do our
best to answer every question we're just
a short shareable less than 140
character response we also put the text
to these minimal Maxim's in the show
notes so you can copy and share our pith
the answers on social media if you like
and now you can find all of our quotes
in one place
minimal maxims calm our first lightning
round question is from jewel jewel says
I have lots of items like games that
have pieces missing I know the missing
pieces are in my house somewhere and the
game is no good to anyone with missing
pieces but the stack of things I'm ready
to part with that have missing pieces is
overwhelming
I want to get rid of things consciously
throwing things away that could be
useful as soon as I find the missing
piece seems wasteful help oh my god that
is like there's so many metaphors here
there's so many metaphors and that
question like just reading it exhaust to
me I could only imagine the the the
exhaustion that drool is feeling from
this this question that is constantly
rather what idling around in their head
so the metaphors that I see not just
sentence but like she actually had to
posit this question in two separate
tweets her life is so overwhelmed she
couldn't fit it into two hundred and
eighty characters and I totally get it
and we're missing it because we feel
like we need to collect all the pieces
everything is relevant right so I'm
gonna I mean what's two hundred eighty
times to Ryan quick math podcast this is
two hundred eighty times two is five
sixty but that's not the point
Jule everything is relevant dude even
the things that aren't relevant and
drool is making relevant that's what I'm
saying everything feels so relevant
right so urgent we can make I can make
this piece of paper relevant right even
though it's not important right and so
so first thing I think she needs to do I
I didn't really write this down but she
needs to delineate urgent from important
because that's the big thing that we
often confuse everything becomes urgent
and now these puzzle pieces all of a
sudden are urgent you need to cancel
these puzzles and you have seven days to
find the piece otherwise you have to let
it go now letting it go means trashing
it so you because it's not useful to
someone else right but there's also a
beautiful metaphor in here maybe the
puzzle just like life is never going to
be fully complete and maybe that's
beautiful right but you're not getting
value from it anymore either way so give
yourself seven days you've cancelled it
right now you have seven days to let go
of this thing let me give you my pit the
answer here
the best way to declutter is to avoid
new clutter before it enters your home
and so to me this is really I wanted to
expand on this because she's gonna let
go of this but the same thing is going
to happen there's gonna be other things
that have missing pieces right really
why is she afraid to let go here right
it's just fear
the it's not the puzzle piece it's not
the puzzle piece it's holding her back
it's her fear of letting go question too
is like let's say she's got a monopoly
game and it's got some missing pieces to
it and she gonna play Monopoly if she
finds the pieces like that's the
question maybe maybe you know jewel is
concerned like well I've got this game
and it's got missing pieces and no I'm
not gonna play the game but if I do find
the missing pieces I could donate and
someone else could play the game well
that mean you're gonna be constantly
caught up in this limbo of justifying
the things that we hold on to I love the
idea of giving herself a deadline well
here's the thing here's my here's my
pithy answer holding on to something
incomplete will make you feel just that
incomplete yes indeed
so jewel the feeling that you have it's
gonna get better if you let those things
go and you know what you might let them
go you might give yourself a week you go
through your house you try to find the
missing pieces you don't find the
missing pieces the week is up you go and
get rid of that stuff and maybe you find
the missing piece the following week
it's okay it's not the end of the world
I mean the the the the game that you're
holding on to with missing pieces this
is a physical object and physical object
whether it's sitting in your house
whether it's sitting in a donation
warehouse whether it's sitting in
recycling bin whether it's sitting in
the trash like that thing exists yeah
out of all the places I just named where
it could be sitting the worst place it
could be sitting is in your house yeah
that's by far the worst place and by the
way there's an additional sort of
problem here I mean if I had a puzzle at
my house right now and there was a piece
missing I'd be able to find it within an
hour mm-hmm but that's not that hasn't
always been the case and remember my old
house back in in Ohio imagine if I lost
a puzzle piece there like it could have
been any of those storage bins in my
basement
or my attic or the the third bedroom in
the second closet with it could have
been all of these places so really what
what we're exposing here with jewel has
exposed and this is good news you found
out you have
way too much stuff and that's why you're
losing things like this Ben and I'm not
judging you and saying I think you have
too much stuff what I'm seeing here is
you're saying I have so many things I
can't seem to keep track of all of them
yeah
and that's when it becomes a problem so
do let go of it Julie I promise you're
gonna be more complete with out the
incomplete objects in your life yes
indeed
oh that's pithy to our next question is
from Caroline how do you figure out
which one to do recycle so trash when is
it worth it to go through the hassle of
selling versus donating so this is very
similar to Kristina's question yeah I
think so my pithy answer is when getting
rid of old possessions sell whenever it
makes sense if you can't sell in 30 days
and I'm changing that now I'm going to
change that to seven days no leg on
change this in the minimal Maxim's so
this is really my recipe for for letting
go so I'll start over again when getting
rid of old possessions sell whenever it
makes sense if you can't sell in seven
days
donate immediately if you can't donate
recycle if you can't recycle trash it
and I just want to talk real quick about
the be one in ten out rule Yemen a new
essay on our website about it's
something that really helped me early on
because I was so overwhelmed with
letting go but I was also overwhelmed by
well of course I want to bring new
things in am I never allowed to bring
anything new into my life now that I'm
becoming a minimalist well no I and so I
found a way to sort of do both any time
I wanted to bring something very
intentionally into my life something new
a new t-shirt I had the red let go of
ten items so if it was a new t-shirt it
was like ten pieces of clothing I'm
going to let go a new blender I asked
let go of ten kitchen items and so forth
and so on and and what you realized in
that process is like oh the things I'm
bringing them into my life I'm curating
and bringing in only the things I need
but then also it's forcing me before I
can go buy the item to let go of those
ten things so I'll put a link to that in
the show notes as well we're just like
reliving my leg clutter and and getting
rid of my clutter yeah and it's just I
feel so good to get rid of it man like I
suspect we get to get to good terms with
that with that uh that economic terms
cost it just reading man it's so freeing
all right my short answer is this
there's a it's this Josh there's an
official rule book for minimalism and
you're the author so here's the thing
Caroline that the one in ten out of the
twenty twenty rule thirty thirty rule
would 1990 rule the whatever it is these
are Josh and i's rules that we use we
have written our own rulebook and we
differ on a couple of rules yeah and
it's okay
but like Carolyn you get to write the
rules what are your rules what does your
meaningful life look like what is gonna
make sense for your household you know
when I think about the ninety nine year
old for example that is a great rule it
doesn't work all the time for me because
I got things like a snowboard and stuff
that isn't really necessarily going to
fall into that rule but setting up these
boundaries are what helps us to get
through these questions but but yeah
Caroline you get to write the rule book
and the nice thing about that is uh is
creating rules that challenge you you
don't want rules that are easy that's
not the whole point of this right you
get to write that rule book so that you
can challenge yourself that there's a
new essay owner on our website Reese I
wrote about my rule of two and and for
me it's like I get overwhelmed with a
lot of health stuff because I've been
radically improving my and my health
over the last two years or so and I want
to do everything every day I want to
make sure I go to the sauna and I want
to do my push-ups and my pull-ups and my
squats and I want to make it to the gym
I was good therapy yeah physical therapy
and cycling and yoga and and sauna and
but all these things that I want to do
and it becomes overwhelming and so the
rule that I made for myself was still
challenging it's there are eleven things
I like to do every single week twice a
week and and of those things as long as
I do them twice I give myself permission
to feel satisfied and then if I do them
more than twice I feel like a champion
as opposed to changing the expectation
if it was every day and I only did them
six times it'd be like oh you failed so
set set some rules up that that are
difficult but they also don't set you up
for failure you don't want to set up
rules that are impossible for you you
don't want the five five rule if I
haven't used in this the last five days
I have to get rid of it immediately
Bobby uses the last five minutes one of
the next five minutes standing there
naked yeah so so create rules that are
empowering that allow you to move
forward in the right direction allow you
to grow but also keep in mind you want
rules there that challenge you a PS Ryan
we have one more question we do how do
you get rid of sentimental items my
daughter is 20 years old but I still
have boxes of her baby toys in the
garage so we're gonna talk about that
and right it's not just about the baby
toys I mean that that's one aspect of it
but sentimental items as a whole is it's
a really difficult thing and so let's
talk about that on this week's
PostScript episode
exclusively on the minimalist private
podcast over at patreon so I just wanna
say thanks real quick to our patreon
supporters you all are the ones that
keep the lights on we we have this
podcast it's a hundred percent
advertisement free but you help us pay
for podcast Sean we have a great
producer we have video Jordin we don't
have a good name for him Jordin no more
but we're working on it yeah if you have
any nickname ideas put him in the
comments below any - that's right so
Jordans putting this up on on YouTube
for us and in filming the whole thing
he's our filmmaker here and a great
addition to the team
of course we have Jess who handles the
social media stuff and so we don't do
any advertisements because it doesn't
really align with with our values and
there are certainly ways you can do
advertisements where it will align with
with your values and so I'm not judging
people who have a different podcast it
just it doesn't work for us and so
patreon you are the reason that we're
able to do this we're able to have this
beautiful studio space and we're really
grateful for that and because of that we
give you some extra freebies ever every
week we record a PostScript episode it's
a little short morsel usually about 5 to
20 minutes long a bonus episode that
comes out every Wednesday on the
minimalist private podcast feed and that
shows up right there and your regular
podcast players if you're listening to
this on Apple podcast you're listening
to this on overcast or whatever you just
get this personal link and if you are a
supporter on patreon then every week
you'll get this little bonus episode we
also do episodes of ask the minimalists
anything and we do live streams we do
o our live of
Vince you get access to our live events
we've put in putting out at least one
live event a month for the past I think
year or so now over on patreon you can
have access to all of that if you want
just head on over to the minimalists
comm a slash support you can find all
the details and good stuff over there
and here is a snippet from this week's
PostScript episode could you imagine
like instead of having pictures of your
kid in your wallet you just had your kid
in your wallet have you met Johnny no I
I think I think that's so important Ryan
because yes the the those are the
triggers for memories but also it's a if
you take it a step further you're also
not gonna have a thousand pictures of
the big wheel right one picture suffices
and so maybe if you have a thousand
sentimental items maybe just a handful
of sentimental items you'll get far more
value from those few sentimental items
then if you water them down with an
entire basement of unused I'll say
sentimental items in quotes because
they're not actually sentimental to you
if you're holding on to everything if
everything is precious
then nothing actually is okay now it's
time for our added value portion in the
shows where we each talk about something
that has added value to our lives
recently the TV show Barry is well this
is so the way I wrote this down here
it's a serious comedy show
okay so jon heder is the star he won an
Emmy last night actually for the
maintenance yeah yeah I didn't watch it
but I saw it on Twitter this morning and
then Henry Winkler won his first Emmy
he's in Barry as well he has Best
Supporting Actor 42 years after he was
first nominated what is Henry Winkler I
know I know the Fonz oh yeah okay yeah
so he was nominated 42 years ago and
this is his first Emmy win that's great
Best Supporting Actor latians man he do
die I know he's like known as the Fonz
but he's been in
so many random things like one thing I
think about is Arrested Development he
was like the lawyer in this hilarious
show that had no resin wasn't is
hilarious I've not seen it oh my god did
he just said she could anyway I just I'm
so happy for him that's awesome well in
it's a great show it's the the main
character and this is a spoiling
anything this is the first the very
first scene he is a contract hitman
Barry is yeah yeah Jon Heder is okay but
he plays it really well and and then he
goes out to LA to do this job and he
gets involved in the acting scene
accidentally because he's supposed to
kill someone and he was an actor and
then he like starts taking this acting
class and Henry Winkler okay is the the
the teacher the teacher of the acting
class and he's like a failed actor but
he's just teaching this acting class and
it one of the scenes that happens is Jon
Heder is a terrible actor in his
character Barry is a terrible actor in
John haters not a terrible actor by the
way he's phenomenal in this but Barry is
a is a just of this terrible I he's he's
um Whitman and his character is a
terrible actor all right and so he he
has to do a scene from Glengarry Glen
Ross just a preface at home Josh and I
when we worked in the corporate world we
would always play this Glengarry Glen
Ross scene it's a movie with Al Pacino
in it but it's this scene where alec
baldwin comes in and it's this very I
mean now it makes me cringe thinking
about it but at the time it was like
this hard-ass boss who came in and he
was gonna turn the sales guys around and
he was gonna make him do their job and
he was you know threatening everything
but killing them essentially oh it was
inspiring back then and now it's
inspiring for totally the horizon like I
don't ever want to be in that world
again right yeah no doubt dude so so he
so he his first audition or his first
scene is the practice Gary Glen Ross
yeah supposed to be like a hard-ass yes
boss he's coming in and he's laying down
the law
exactly I'm here from Mitch & Murray I'm
here on a mission of
from God what's that Oh am I saying I've
been said okay Jordan Jordan Jordan has
corrected me it is Bill Hader Thank You
drew thank you yeah it is not John and
John hater was Napoleon Dynamite is that
right or no okay anyway maybe I'm just
making it up yeah
Bill Hader anyway he's phenomenal in
there and he has this scene but he he
has only red he's never seemed like very
Glen Ross either the play or the movie
and so he goes in there being the nice
guy who say I want to persuade these
people and you the weird thing is you
have to have the contact at least go to
youtube and find the scene of of Alec
Baldwin playing Blake in Glengarry Glen
Ross it's like a nine minute monologue
and it is some of the best acting you
ever see but then then Bill Hader is his
character Barry is it he has to play it
up and it's so good the contrast between
nice guy because the weird thing is you
can actually read the script as a nice
person
oh my guys are no second prize is a set
of steak knives
third prize you're fired but the good
news is you've got one week to earn your
job Alec Baldwin is third prize you're
fired
yeah all of you have one week you have
exactly one week to earn your jobs back
yeah it'sit's such a good scene so Barry
is available I don't know where I don't
even know I don't have cable TV it on
iTunes or whatever all right bananas out
of your life I am lucky enough to be
able to see Capitol Records roof from
where I live and a few weeks ago I saw
someone performing a concert I could
hear it from my from my place I saw some
performing a concert and I was like oh
my god like this sounds like Troy 7
turns out it was Troy 7 on the rooftop
of Capitol Records but he was uh playing
some songs from his new album called
bloom in dude it's yeah it's a great
it's a great album I would highly
recommend it I dig I really really loved
his his first album yeah what's called
blue the blue neighborhood oh yeah it is
blue neighborhood I loved it I haven't
gotten into this one as much because
I've listed a few other albums but it's
there where
like I really want to I really want to
dive deep into it yeah so yeah all right
Troye Sivan balloon alright let's move
on to right here right now where we talk
about what's going on in the lives of
the minimalist my partner Rebecca in
October is doing her 23-day priorities
reset and you can check that out over at
minimal wellness.com
she's a dietician nutritionist and also
an amazing shape and she also people
reset the priority so they can get their
health back on track and she works with
only 30 people at a time and so that
tends to fill up if you're interested in
that it's minimal wellness comm we've
raised over $40,000 so far for the gyms
the update was last week yeah I think so
that's great and it keeps improving but
it is it is tapered off a bit so we need
your help well you know I was thinking
dude I just finally saw the documentary
America left behind yes then we talked
about on last week's City podcast almost
made me want to move back to Dayton Ohio
I felt the same because it needs so much
help there and you know what I will say
man that that documentary it does show
the despair and it highlights the the
despair it absolutely does there is hope
though I mean I do feel like there is a
lot of Hope in Dayton and gem city is
one of those hopes it is because you and
I know a lot of the people in Dayton
yeah and they didn't do a great job
highlighting the hope although I saw the
hope it's like when you have a dark dark
room you know you turn the light off
that's over our head right now it's
gonna be dark in here yeah but you turn
on a a five watt bulb all of a sudden
you can see again that's kind of what
what the documentary America I left
behind America did for me was it shine a
little 5 watt bulb in this dark room so
ok so here's what I was thinking is if
somehow we could get everyone who is
listening to this to watch just watch
that that hour-long documentary America
left behind yeah I think that will help
people it will inspire them to help
Dayton Ohio and it's beautifully shot I
know Josh and I are biased towards
Dayton Ohio because we're from there but
Dayton Ohio is true especially West
Dayton they need so much help right now
40% of the city lives in West Dayton
there's not a single grocery store
in the entire westside of Dayton Podcast
Shawn can you put a link to the PBS
documentary in the show notes just check
it out it's an hour long it's a it's a
very well shot documentary you know take
Dayton out of it take you know gem city
market out of it I mean it's just it's a
it's a great documentary it's worth the
watch but I'm I am like extra motivated
to get to this hundred thousand bucks
for gem city
yeah after watching that documentary by
the way you're familiar with Dayton even
if you're not Dayton is Akron Dayton is
Buffalo Dayton is Flint Michigan Dayton
is Detroit Dayton is Fort Wayne Indiana
Dayton is Saginaw Dayton is is any of
these cities there's sort of in the Rust
Belt that have been struggling since the
a the decline of the 80s and beyond and
really started in the 60s but Dayton was
also the thriving city it was the
Silicon Valley of of its time of the
early 1900s the center of innovation
yeah and it has changed but there is
hope and if you see that documentary I
agree Jim City is actually a featured so
excuse me somewhere toward the end of it
and if you want to donate even if you
have $1 $5 $10 $20 $1,000 then just go
to the minimalists comm slash Dayton
that won't even take you to our website
for words over to the Jim City Market
donation page that we have set up and
we're trying to raise $100,000 so we can
help them build this nonprofit grocery
co-op on the west side of Dayton and we
really need your help let's get to
$100,000 you know you know even if let's
say there's a lot people out there who
don't even have a dollar to donate if
you live in Dayton go sign for the soup
kitchen or something I mean there it's
so funny like I was when I was watching
the documentary I thought to myself man
you know if they just had the
infrastructure and I'm like wait a
minute like they don't need I mean they
do need a grocery store don't get me
wrong but money is not gonna solve West
Dayton's problem know what's gonna solve
a date ins problem is community
absolutely so if you don't have a dollar
if you live in Dayton and you don't have
a dollar to donate at least go go
volunteer for some kind of social
program to to help out Dayton I promise
you like a you're gonna meet some
awesome people when you volunteer your
time but be like that impact is it's
huge it's gonna be so huge totally agree
new on our website right now if you go
over to
minimalists calm there was a new essay
up there delete 1000 photos in 11 days I
put together a recipe for you to donate
or you can donate your photos now
delete delete a thousand photos in 11
days a bit of a recipe for that there
also a link to the scanning party if you
have a bunch of physical photos you
don't know what to do with there's
something called a scanning party that
Ryan and I tend to recommend that has
worked out really well for us if you
want to comment on this episode you can
do so over at youtube.com slash the
minimalist and you can also find over
there on YouTube our living room
conversations we're putting them up
every week and we're sort of alternating
back and forth between my place and
ryan's place and we're doing some solo
episodes we also brought some guests on
as well we have a meaningful life
episode number one as our first vlog
recap is up there right now we've got
some house tours of both of our homes
coming soon and if you want the podcast
show notes
we always hear us talk about the show
notes to this podcast head on over to
the minimalists comm and put your email
address there at the top we'll send you
the the podcast show notes any new
writings as well any time that we
release a podcast episode we'll never
send you any spam because that stuff is
gross Ryan what else you got here are
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners hi my name is Tricia and I
am from London Michigan and I was
listening to the podcast on curation and
I wanted to share my experience in case
it would help someone else I recently
led a collection go as a child I
collected the state quarters about once
every few weeks my dad would bring home
a Rhode Island quarter for me and had
always forgotten that I already had
Rhode Island he died suddenly when I was
in middle school
from then on I collected all the Rhode
Island quarters that I came across after
listening to your podcast and changing
the way I look at stuff
I let the collection of quarters go two
weeks ago now when I come across the
Rhode Island quarter when paying for
things I smile and know the memory is
still there even though the collection
is gone the quarter still has maybe
meaning to me without being piled some
in my house hi st. Louis I was listening
to an older episode on consumerism a
recommendation for the big-box stores I
actually use Amazon subscribe and save
and I order all of my non waste of all
things such as my toilet paper tissues
cetera each month
it also takes me out of the stores by
doing that because I only order the
essential and then I'm spending less
than if I went to Target or somewhere
else so I think Amazon
I would say or something similar would
be agree out hi my name is Maria and I'm
in Auburn Washington I was listening to
your episode on clothing and I wanted to
share another option filling your own
clothes there's a huge movement toward
family clothing right now so the
resources patterns fabric and
inspiration are pretty endless and I
think this option would appeal to a lot
of those wanting to live a more minimal
and intentional lifestyle when you sell
your own clothes you appreciate them
more and wear them with pride it's also
a great conversation starter and you no
longer have clothes with tag or logos
advertising to the world you can also
choose sustainably made fabrics so you
know your clothes were ethically made
from the start to finish you no longer
have to go clothes shopping as much so
you won't be tempted to consume at the
stores you get to be creative when your
skills and you get to listen to the
middle minimalist podcast while you sew
many of the pattern companies and fabric
shops are also small independently owned
businesses owned by people doing
something they love and I love
supporting that alright y'all that's it
for this episode if you have a question
for the minimalists give us a call for
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine you can also email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists comm and if
you all leave here with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time and minimus